tout ça est très essoufflée je vous
avoue jusqu'à un certain point comme les
investisseurs doivent réagir sur dix la
chapelle bonsoir vous êtes unificatrice
financière vous travaillez donc avec des
gens qui essayent de planifier leurs
finances vous leur dites quoi ce soir
quelle semaine anxiogène et un peu
essoufflée au bout de sept semaines
au final j'ai le goût de zéro au genre
après l'émission ce soir de fermer la
télé puis de l'information qui circule
peut accélérer le sentiment de danse
étaient des gens et les émotions
négatives associées à toutes ces
nouvelles de chute des marchés boursiers
au montant que parler de cela cette
semaine
toutefois le conseil que je donne à mes
clients et à tous les investisseurs
c'est de vraiment garder ça y est la
raison des émotions donc ça forme une
banalité on le répète souvent mais dans
une période comme cette semaine il faut
vraiment revenir à l'essentiel est resté
rester raisonnable donc notre institut
précédemment le mentionnait sein des
pôles temps devant vous a déjà investi
en actions
faut pas céder à la panique cette
semaine c'est le sait le conseil de base
mais si on pense que ça va baisser
davantage et des gens qui vous ont dit
jusqu'où ça va bien si vous savez pas je
ne sais pas c'est ça on aimerait tous ce
sera donc peut-être que des gens qui
vont se dire lundi matin je préfère
arrêter tout de suite parce que je
crains une chute encore plus important
dans les prochains jours en termes
d'investissements dans le passé le passé
n'est pas garant de l'avenir mais quand
même
historiquement quand il ya des creux il
ya des reprises donc c'est la durée le
tac ça va prendre pour la reprise qui
est incertain mais chose chaussures si
on encaisse une perte
on n'a aucune chance de les rattraper
ce que je veux mentionner par contre
c'est que
le corona virus accélérer la correction
boursière mais ça fait quand même
plusieurs mois qu'on parle d'une
correction boursière à venez voir sur la
table c'est ça qu'on a mis des
corrections boursières qui sont moins
moins sévères mais la plupart des
investisseurs ont le plan masqué qui est
prêt depuis depuis quelques mois ça fait
quand même un peu france a fait deux ans
qu'on dit à nos clients faut se préparer
il faut se préparer donc si on a une
planification de portefeuille qui est
dans un objectif long terme et qui est
équilibré on en a vu on a vu le coup
venir on l'a on pensait pas finalement
qu'ils allaient venir aussi vite en 2020
un accélérateur avec le coronavirus mais
il n'y a pas de surprise aujourd'hui sur
la correction boursière anormal non plus
de voir des soubresauts boursiers
actionnaires comme cela donc c'est un
peu le rôle jadis des fois la blague que
notre métier ses conseillers des
investissements mais c'est aussi par
beaucoup depuis ce que le gie avec les
investisseurs donc de garder une
relation plus raisonnable par rapport à
leurs portefeuilles ne pas aller voir
cette semaine trolls et les valeurs
baisser pour pas céder à la panique qui
vendent au mauvais moment et donc vous
leur dites que c'est une occasion aussi
c'est une occasion de profiter en guimet
d'une correction boursière
oui effectivement donc je partage le
point de vue de l'inviter précédemment
c'est à dire que des façons de profiter
de ses occasions
l'investissement le mais il faut voir
que les gestionnaires en trop des fonds
à des fonds communs d'investissement
depuis plusieurs mois son centre est
liquide donc on sont prêts à investir et
quand ils vont voir les opportunités
accueilli comme investisseur faut garder
ça en tête
donc il ya toujours des occasions
d'affaires qui vont émaner d'une
correction boursière
il ya des façons de le faire donc un
truc qu'on mentionne souvent aux gens
c'est l'investissement par son ratio
périodiques par sommes fixes de façon
irrégulière
donc si un mode horde aussi dans les
prochains dans les prochaines semaines
c'est vraiment de profiter de ces
systèmes de pare était d'investir mais
de profiter des systèmes d'achats
périodiques pour dans le fond pouvoir se
prémunir contre la
le risque se fait à la volatilité du
marché actuel parce que si vous
investissez 100 500 ou 1000 $ le dis par
exemple vous achetez plus bas qu'il y a
une semaine ou une semaine exactement
mais peut-être plus haut que la semaine
prochaine ça continue et donc la seule
période dite c'est que ça permettra de
répartir le coût moyen dans l'année et
profiter du marché un petit peu chaque
semaine donc si on a des gros
investissements faire c'est vraiment la
stratégie de ceux actuellement et se
diversifient toujours c'est toujours le
mot clé est la diversification nous
exactement donc l'objectif d'un
portefeuille s'est passé parce que nous
formons le rendement tout prix c'est de
faire des bons choix d'investissement
donc les gens qui étaient très confiants
depuis dix ans ont peut-être certaines
personnes ont pu faire des stratégies
qui sont très très concentré mais les
gens qui ont un portefeuille équilibré
stratégie de long terme
on garde le cap évidemment pour les gens
qui étaient plus près de la retraite ça
commence à faire un certain temps que
qu'on sécurise un peu les portefeuilles
en prévision de ce qui se passe
actuellement
donc en principe on est moins touché que
par ce qui se passe présentement parce
qu'on est supposé avoir une partie du
portefeuille qui est exposé aux actions
qui est plus faible que si on est en
période d'accumulation et la retraite et
dans 25 ans donc pour les gens qui sont
en phase d'accumulation moi je peux vous
à cette semaine au bureau avec la date
limite de cotisation pour l'erreur 2019
qui savent qu'ils aient une vie j'ai pas
senti que ça allait freiner les
investissements des épargnants tu
m'étonnes ben mon site
enfin c'est ce qu'il épaule elle
provoque une personne qui est 30 40 45
ans il va avoir d'autres
d'autres corrections boursières d'autres
récessions donc cécile c'est tout à fait
normal les crises financières sont en or
sont anormales belle et les cycles
économiques sont un phénomène tout à
fait régulier donc faut apprendre à
vivre avec avec ces phénomènes là c'est
sûr que des personnes qui sont en face
de décaissements sont un petit peu plus
c'est très sexuellement de d'entendre
une nouvelle de voir tous ces chiffres
ces corrections boursières ces chefs à
la base merci beaucoup pour ces quelques
mots et bon courage
oui exactement merci beaucoup c'est ns
et la chaufferie merci bien